uh as soon as we have all the
senators here i will
start the meeting
good morning and welcome to uh the skull
committee meeting on october
22nd
our first order of business is
acceptance of the minutes
uh could i have a motion to accept the
minutes please
a second
thank you
are there any changes
on the minutes
senator daniels thank you madam chair uh
on page seven
uh the paragraph just before
late informational item
i would like to add
language in there so that the paragraph
reads the committee requested the
department of education returned to the
october 1st meeting with an update on
the voucher program
the number of students enrolled
then adding the language where the
students were from comma
if the
if that district had a masked mandate
policy comma and and then
what what effect
it might have on the budget
thank you
um could i
yes there is
excuse me um please use your microphones
set on yeah so would the senator please
consider adding uh just another couple
of words to say
and other demogra other student
demographics is available
if they're going to go into a detailed
review it'd be nice to know
everything we can about the the
population that is accepting these
grants
the the reason i added this language in
is i asked the commissioner specifically
for those two things i didn't ask them
for other demographics i i had
offline so i don't think it would be a
surprise i think he's got the data
senator morris
i this is only to record minutes so it
would be what was said publicly that day
if if you're going to have to keep it to
that yeah uh could you
okay
it's all you said now
so the motion uh we have on the floor or
the amendment we have on the floor
is as stated by
senator daniels
all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand
opposed
abstain
okay thank you very much two abstentions
okay the motion now is um
accept the minutes as amended
to our september 17th 2021 meeting
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
abstain
thank you very much
madam chair if i may just quickly uh
mike kane down here
um just going forward since this is
being live streamed when a motion is um
made and seconded if you could just
announce the member making that motion
in that second because sometimes there's
multiple it'd be easier for the public
to follow okay thank you
no no problem i'm sorry
okay turning now to tab three
are there any items to come off the
uh
consent calendar in tab three
uh senator rosenwald
thank you
thank you madam chair
um i know that it's the only item but i
do have questions on this item for the
department
sure and i believe if there's a member
of gopher available yeah that'd be
helpful
yeah i will
yeah
i just want to remind everybody to
please speak directly into the
microphones
up close and personal
because
it is live streaming
and it's difficult for those in
the audi the live streaming audience to
hear us
i pulled the chair today that's really
low
[Laughter]
but i will try to speak right into the
mic thank you thanks for being here um i
have questions on both the
the homeless part and the long-term care
part on the homeless
part um there's six million dollars in
total appropriated
it i couldn't tell how much of that was
for shelters but my question is how much
of that is for shelters and
if
if our reimbursement for a night in a
shelter is eight dollars a day but the
cost is 47 a day
what will the impact of the part of the
6 million
dollars be and then i have a question if
i could about the long-term care
okay the blue red red button red button
i was pressing the green button sorry
uh senator thank you for that question
yes so uh these will be for shelters uh
it is a total six million dollars is for
the shelter community and it is
exclusively for their code related
expenses over the course of the last two
years we're using cares act fund for
these dollars
so uh we'll need to uh work with them
there's a list of eligible expenses
including things like hvac systems and
new new space
and configurations right down to
cleaning supplies
and so this is part of an effort to
get these funds out here before the
weather gets bad and have them put into
use prior to the end of the year
so so none of it is to increase shelter
rates that
hhs had
said to us they would
tell us by august or september
what their plan was to increase shelter
rates and
it's almost november this this because
we're using this from cares act we
needed to have it be something that
could apply prior to the end of the year
and so we extended the care the expense
program uh to be able to get some
resources to the shelters in
anticipation of the coming winter season
so none of this will increase our
reimbursement from eight dollars a day
no ma'am thank you and on the long-term
care the 11 and a half million
i'm um
i'd like to know
um
how how that number was arrived at
because it's my understanding that the
nursing homes were not
involved in
the discussion of
that appropriation so what is the impact
of this 11 and a half million
going to be on this really struggling
sector
so i'm going to this is chase again
who's our deputy director at gopher and
i think that's a good question thank you
the answer for you hi senator can
everyone hear me okay happy to answer
the question um the number was arrived
at by taking the known long-term care
facility beds in the state and
multiplying it by the stipend for those
beds so it's just a set amount known on
based on the known universe of beds it
based on how this is structured it
didn't necessarily require additional
outreach to those facilities to to
understand the cost
if just a quick follow-up so what is the
stipend per bed
thank you are there any further
questions on this uh item
yes representative leishman
uh you're not talking into the mic
thanks matt there we go
thanks madam chair
nope oh i guess i have to hold it down
right if you're using the blue button
you have to hold it down
you can also just press the red button
once right and it'll stay there we go
a follow follow-up to senator
rosenwald's uh question
as far as the breakdown of the 39
million dollars who made that final
decision was it you a commissioner or do
you have like people still
are making recommendations
to you with how that breakdown has
arrived at so the 39 million dollar
number in this item is effectively a
reassembly of existing resources from
programs that have closed
uh from some of the recruitment
activities that are underway right now
so that we can get them into the class
lines that are necessary to close out
the program
this program cares act crf program is
required to close by the end of this
calendar year so so the uh what roughly
uh 20 something million dollars in the
three programs that are outlined in this
item
are the uh result of that reassembly
into some items that we know where we
can get some money out to make a
difference in these areas in the senior
centers in the food security area and
the long-term care beds uh prior to the
end of this year so that we get that
number down as low as we can possibly
get it so we aren't sending any of those
funds back to the federal government
just to follow up man i'm chair please
and and we is who
we
well we've been the departed gopher
has been the uh entity that has been
responsible for the completion of the
cares act program in coordination
obviously with the governor's office
okay thanks
are there any further
yes senator mars
i i think we should point out that if
this money isn't spent it goes
to unemployment
that's right at the end anything that's
left over as you recall is in that what
we call a waterfall
or that will go into the unemployment
trust fund
senator d'alessandra
thank you
thank you madam chair uh
at the last meeting of the gopher
committee which i was a member of we set
aside 25 million dollars in reserve
is the 39.5
is that 25 part of the 39.5
that was uh set aside that's that's
number one
and number two
where did the additional money come from
it was from unexpected monies that we
had allocated
i'm a little confused by the second
question the
the difference between the 25 and the
five is that monies that were returned
that were allocated but weren't spent
yes in some part yes those are the
recruitment funds uh that have been
coming back into dra
as a result of the main street program
the self program the gap program that
we're now currently trying to
recirculate back into the business
community through the recoupment and
expense programs
as part of our wind-up of the of the
program are there any further questions
yes senator morris
i'll make a motion about the past okay
do i have a second
senator d'alessandro
okay
all right
all those in favor please raise your
hand
vote is ten
zero
thank you
okay
tab four
um
does anyone want to remove the one item
in tab four
senator gaiden
21 293 madam chair
no we're still in tab four which is uh
two one two nine seven okay
could i have a motion to approve
thank you
senator d'alessandro second second
senator daniels
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
the vote is ten zero
now we go to tab five
are there any items that anyone would
like to take off
the consent calendar under tab five
senator guida
21 293 madam chair just for a brief
question of safety okay thank you
anyone else
okay uh could i have a motion to madam
chair senator roosevelt i'm sorry
senator roosevelt
thank you um item 309.
okay is there anything else
hold up
saying none i would take a motion to oh
sorry 305 madam chair 21 305. mike said
i said that i could just ask
300.
okay is there anything else
all right
i have 293
and 309
off the consent calendar
could i have a motion to approve the
other items in tab five move the
remainder madam chair thank you
senator yeah representative leichmann
and second by
senator d'alessandro
all those in favor please raise your
hand
the vote is 10 0.
okay
all right uh fis 21 293
senator geida you had a question from
safety
thank you madam chair question for
safety uh very briefly
mr lavoie
is this allocation of funds related to
the improved background check process
that was passed i believe under uh rep
then representative hennessey's bill
several years ago this is part of that
ongoing
uh renovation of our background check
process uh indirectly yes so uh for the
record steve lavoie director of
administration for the department of
safety
these are we're continually working to
expand the ability to capture
fingerprints across the state especially
in key areas where there's high volume
and this grant funding will allow us to
increase our live scan 10 print capture
machines adding 10 to the 59 that are
already in place across new hampshire
follow-up yes
is this in response to the significant
backlog of fingerprinting requests it is
yes it's it's one component of our uh of
the work that the department is doing to
get through that backlog we need to
increase the ability to capture
fingerprints across the state due to the
increased demand for the service we also
need to increase the ability to process
those once they're captured so we're
adding additional time over time for
processing and then also making
improvements to the process uh working
closely with the fbi to make sure that
quality control is happening at an
appropriate level and that extra work's
not being done thank you thank you madam
chair okay
uh are there any other questions for
safety on this
second
move the adoption of 293 thank you
represent our senator daniels
uh moves uh
yeah fis 21 293
seconded by uh senator gaida
is there any further discussion
seeing none
uh all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
the vote the vote is 10
zero
okay we now turn to um
fis21305
department of health and human services
authorization to accept and expend
dollars in federal funds through
september
30th 2022.
thank you i didn't write down who pulls
it off
senator guide thank you madam chair
commissioner uh thank you for showing
today
my question is fairly simple it's a
broad one is this consistent with the
recently passed constitutional amendment
regarding personal privacies is any way
conflicted with that
there's no conflict with that thank you
very much
are there further questions on this item
saying none could i have a motion to
accept
senator d'allesandro second
and senator gaida
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
being none the vote is ten zero
fis21309
uh senator rosenwald has some additional
questions on this
thanks
i i know it's related to the next item
but um
there's 180 million dollars
in this um housing assistance fund that
um wondering how long the program's been
in operation and what percentage
of those 180 million dollars have been
encumbered
um
you're talking about the uh emergency
rental program yes so uh there are two
tranches of that resource there's the
what we refer to as era one which came
in late december of 2020
2020 and then there was a second
era that came later in the year and
together those are
just over 300 million dollars
at this point
i think where we are is
the
federal government has um informed us
that they're going to start tracking the
percentage that we are utilizing and
then over the course of the next couple
of months implement the formula
that will
eventually start taking back funds that
are unneeded
this is part of what you're seeing in
this item is
to be able to continue to spend those
resources in eligible activities under
those programs so that we're returning
as little as possible under those funds
well so of the 180 million dollars
i think that was in
um era one
what percentage have we encumbered
i'm going to ask chase to answer that
question so um
currently on gopher's website there's a
dashboard that tracks this fund and the
program uh which has been in existence
since i think march or april of this
year and i believe it's already spent
about 50 million dollars
um i think the original authorization
for this program considered 80 million
so that was what we
anticipated could potentially be run
through over the course of time under
era 1 before era 2 came along so now
there
the federal government is sort of
deciding how much of each is going to
stay with each state moving forward
did you have a follow-up
okay
are there any further questions
senator daniels
thank you uh
question is to uh
what services are
are offered under housing stability
services and what's it mean
to keep households stably housed
so under this program what it the what
the
what the goal is is to as it says keep
people in housing and to make sure that
they get into housing and we do that
through individualized case-by-case um
services that are provided on-site for
those individuals at each of the
shelters
so whether it's you know applying for
funding that's available either under
the era program or under any other
programs
and
and those types of services to make sure
that they're made taking full advantage
of all of what's available to them right
now to keep them in housing
are there any further questions
i i do have one
quick question um
are you
are you projecting that all of this
money will be used
or are you i mean if we've only
given out what 50 million at this point
what are we going to do to
assist
other folks in housing stability right
so uh as a as a pure rental assistance
number i think the projections are that
the need and the amount that we have
don't line up necessarily but having
said that under the era 2 program
particularly there's a lot more
flexibility for how we can utilize those
funds in order to get at the same
population and and improve the services
such as that we're talking about here
so right now what we're doing is working
with all the parties in on on our side
and with hhs and others to make sure
that we're using all eligible
components of under the program
and get as many of those dollars spent
as we possibly can
okay thank you
any
anyone have any other questions
okay seeing none could i have a motion
pardon move the item
represent the senator gaida do i have a
second
senator daniels
all those in favor of fis21309
please raise your hand
opposed
the vote is ten zero
leishman had his hand up okay so
we'll do that all right all those in
favor please raise your hand
opposed
vote is 10
0.
tab seven
fis
21 296
has been requested by
representative edwards to
move or to be removed from the consent
calendar
uh you have a
i do have a question we'll wait until mr
lavoy
gets a little closer
good morning steve lavoy director of
administration for the department of
safety and with me is justin romanello
the bureau chief of the ems bureau at
the division of fire standards training
and emergency medical services
uh thank you for uh being willing just a
moment please
representative edwards you have a
question i i do thank you madam chair um
so this is a simple one i i see the
money is coming from the department of
health and human services and the
purposes is to create uh or to
facilitate an efficient emergency
evacuation system in the state so um so
it looks like there's obviously some
level of coordination taking place
to um put together
to work cooperatively together to ensure
that we're not doing anything
to create redundancies in it systems or
other human infrastructures could you
could you just talk to us about the
level of coordination between you and
the department of health and human
services to ensure that
in the next many years we have an
efficient coordination between the
departments and that we're not stepping
on each other doing anything redundant
sure no thank you for the question um so
there's definitely coordination that we
have with health and human services one
of the reasons you're seeing this
in the department of safety in this
division is that
the this bureau is responsible for
licensing and oversight of our
of our ambulances our first responders
of the the mobile integrated health
programs as they're being developed in
the state and then also the inter um the
the inter-facility transfers which are
oftentimes done by ambulance um could
also be done by other
non-ambulance related vehicles so that
oversight is um
uh important and and we can't work in a
vacuum and just make these decisions
without input from hhs i think i'd turn
it over to um to the bureau chief to
kind of talk about specifics but we're
absolutely in coordination
so in specific
specifically with mih programs we
currently have a waiver in process for
our providers to waive the health care
license
the home health care license requirement
of a
a worker that would go into the home so
we that's in conjunction with dhhs
that's one way we work uh
collaboratively in addition to that any
mih programs that are approved are done
so with a committee of folks that are
part of our division but also with the
home healthcare association so there's
so there's no overlap of services in
fact the mih programs specifically are
to augment areas that services can't be
rendered
uh thank you man i'm sure so it sounds
like you're both confident that there
are no gaps and overlaps in the the
systems as a result of two different
departments uh running different
portions of it but i just want to ask
you directly
are you concerned of any gaps or
overlaps between yourself
and your your mission and and the
department of health and human services
any gaps any overlaps
everything okay
i'm i'm not concerned with any i don't
know no i think this is fixing it
could i have a motion to accept
i'd like to move the item i'm sorry
excuse me senator daniels thank you good
morning morning director
uh
states here that the overall
effectiveness of the grant will be
determined by the number of emergency
medical services units and providers
trained
can you tell me how many have to be
trained to be successful and why was
that chosen as a metric for for
determining whether you have success of
the program as opposed to reducing the
number of ambulance
so i think i understand your question
sir so uh
ultimately when it comes to mobile
integrated healthcare programs this is
an additional program that services can
elect to provide to their communities
right now we we have about 19 programs
in the state i think we can have much
more because it's really preventing uh
exacerbation of illness so preventing
folks from actually needing an ambulance
uh so i think that even if we just had
one more
that's better in a community in the
state and specifically with mih as far
as inner facility transport we're seeing
times of three to four hours of wait
times and aeds so i think that the more
programs we have that can move the
sickest of our patients around from our
13 critical access hospitals to higher
levels of care
it's going to be an improvement of the
system if we can reduce the three to
four hour wait times by increasing
services such as higher levels of
services so anybody right now that that
has a transport ems service so there's
162 agencies in the state that have an
ambulance that can transport a patient
around
we have specialized care such as
critical care in what we call pift or
paramedic interfacility transport these
programs can move patients that are
sicker
safely around so as we increase
those those specialized services and
increase our services that have the
ability to move those patients around i
think this program will be successful i
think i answered it sir
follow up yes please go ahead so if i
understood you correctly if one person
was trained you would consider the
program successful
i think it would be successful in the
state because that means that one
community is is going to be healthier by
having this program
i i want much more at the end of these
two years as far as programs go but
i think this is going to provide a
resource for us to train many
departments in the safe and effective
transport of patients around the state
as well as as far as mih goes a
different way to approach health care in
treating patients before they get to a
point where not only are they
uh
a higher acuity patient but also they're
they're they're potentially going to
have a better life be a better
better life because they're not
exacerbating to the point where there's
there's downwind effects of that if that
makes sense
um yeah and my my question was
really just in regard to the metric you
chose
to determine whether you know where
we're spending
was at 300
371 000
uh to be determine whether a program is
successful i mean we're always asking
how are you determining if this money
is being uh spent
wisely successfully and i'd say for
to train one person while it may be
an advantage for that community
i'm not sure that it necessarily
computes into a successful program at
one person for 371 000. taking the
consideration
uh your comments about the shortness of
time the reduction in ambulance calls
all those things i would see
see as part of a successful program so
just questioning the you know that your
chosen metric for the success
and um and if i may i think i think part
of the uh challenge that we have is mih
programs mobile integrated health
programs are relatively new um so so
part of this program is to promote that
um that response within the state so
that individuals especially in rural
areas uh are not needing to be
transported by ambulance um
one hour two hours for certain um for
certain activities where there's the the
first responder community can
potentially deliver health care at a
local level
so i believe because this program is
relatively new we only have um how many
do we have 19 in in the state at this
point um
it's difficult we're really looking at
at the beginnings of this program we
want to see more mih programs become
established within the state once
there's more established now we can get
into more
discrete metrics of reducing times and
and that in that matter but we're just
not there yet it's so it's so new
thank you
senator gaiden thank you madam chair
director
thank you for taking my question
um
i am concerned as well as senator
daniels and i'm wondering if the
department would consider providing
the number of new certified providers
as opposed to trainees trainees are
useless unless they're actually
implemented in the provision of the
service
and that would certainly help us get a
better measure of how effective the
program is obviously there's a need and
it's new but i think
would you consider doing that
as far as mih goes i i can
so part of this this initiative is based
off of funds that dhhs accepted uh to
for chronic disease
in the rural areas of the state and so
um
ultimately we're seeing that in the next
few weeks there could be two to three
new mih services
incorporated based on the acceptance of
those funds
and so we want to appropriately support
them and that's why we're high we want
to hire for these three positions
as far as inner facility transport goes
right now dartmouth is your only
critical uh care resource in the state
the single one we have other units
coming in that we will license
eventually but we're working on some
mechanisms to appropriately license
those units right now they're coming in
as what we call mutual aid our paramedic
interfacility transport option that's uh
out of the 162 transport services we
have about 29 services that that have
gone above and beyond and gotten that
extra credential and i feel as though if
we have these positions we can
appropriately support the other 140 ish
my math might be a little off
in achieving that level of uh credential
to appropriately transport those
patients around a brief example we
looked at it recently with a facility
and these numbers are slightly off but a
hospital was calling a local service
that provides 9-1-1 and they do
transfers on occasion
to to the residents um and out of 100
calls 50 percent of them were at a level
that should have been piffed
the service was not a pif service and so
with these positions we would be able to
go out educate the service that hey this
is this is advertised to your population
that you serve to get this additional
credential
right now we just don't have the
resources to do that without taking
those resources from something else
because the section of of the division
is a single captain right now i mean we
need these positions to provide that
support excuse me just a second i think
that all senator guida was looking for
and i think what senator daniels is
looking for
is that maybe in three months you come
back to us with a number
of people
that have been trained and
you know just send something into us you
won't need to come back unless there's a
question but what he's look what we're
what we're looking for is
are we making the progress
that needs to be made
okay yeah so we can we can certainly
provide some some metrics as you're
asking um programs that are being added
um if if i may i'd recommend maybe
within six months three months seems
like a short time frame to to see a lot
of input we need to hire staff um but at
least we can check in within the next
six months how do you know where we're
at and continue to do so on those
intervals
okay thank you very much
uh
could i have a motion to accept
fis-21296
senator d'allesandro
second second senator guide up all
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all opposed
the vote is 10-0
thank you very much
tab 8
could our fish and game people please
come to the table
would you please introduce yourself
uh i'm the executive director of scott
mason new hampshire fish and game
okay uh
based on um
the type of request i guess
this could not go on the consent
calendar sure
and so um
i
would uh are there any questions
that anyone on the committee might have
on this
okay i don't see any
uh if you could just in three minutes
max
explain what this grant is all about
okay
um
we have uh
i believe this is this has come before
you before but it's a it's a three-year
grant so what and we haven't spent much
out of it yet
um so this carries us forward into the
next fiscal cycle
um
we had we purchased a a farm down on
great bay
and there was a um
the deal part of the deal was is the uh
one of the family members could live
there uh
um
until her
and until her death uh that took place
at which point we then
have started on
cleaning the property up and our
our couple our goals there are to
develop a
boat landing historically
there was a boat landing there that in
the in the summertime was a boat landing
in the winter time it was an access
point for uh bob houses for smelt
fishing out on great bay
um there'll be a picnic area and then
housing for uh temporary staff for both
both us and
noah as we have different people coming
through uh doing research in the area
thank you very much
could i have a motion to accept
if i
uh senator d'alessandro do i have a
second
senator daniels
all those in favor
opposed
the vote is 10
0.
uh
tab nine is dealing with the american
rescue plan
are there any items that
anyone would like to take off consent
uh seeing none could i have a mo oh i'm
i'm sorry senator morris i didn't see
you no i was just gonna move the item oh
okay senator morris moves uh tab nine
second
second by senator guida
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
the vote is ten
zero
tab
tab 10.
yes representative edwards uh just just
because we're getting close and i'm not
sure which tab these are in i i want to
make sure that we discuss
314 and 315. i think you already
intend to do that but
oh we're not there yet
are there
any questions on
21-311
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
senator morris do i have a second
senator d'allesandro
all those in favor please raise your
hand
the vote is 10 0.
[Music]
we now turn to tab 11
which
are the
late items
uh the first one is 21 113
from the department of environmental
services
uh
requesting to accept and expend a
hundred thousand dollars per 100 million
dollars
in uh federal
arpa funding
okay
i have uh
representative leitchman has moved
represent senator morris has seconded
are there any questions for the
department
seeing none thank you for coming up and
i think all of us are happy this is
going to move forward
okay all those in favor please raise
your hand
opposed
seeing none the vote is ten
zero
item number 3421-314
uh
from the uh department of
health and human services
representative edwards i believe you
have a couple of questions on this
uh thank you madam chair uh
i i suspect this is a topic that's going
to interest a lot of members of the
committee but um just to to kick it off
uh i i
i i i would just like to hear
the commissioner's version of
of how we got to the point of wanting to
buy the hampstead hospital
and
and what we think we know
about ongoing operations
should we purchase it
and and what we think we know
about what we don't know which is you
know there's probably some issues
related to labor and the like that are
still unsettled so if you could just
tell us
you know your sort of version of of what
where we're at and where we're going
please sure thank you lori shibana
commissioner of health and human
services
i just want to stress that this is
the first phase of many phases that
comes with buying a hospital like
hampstead hospital
it came before us because hampstead
hospital was looking to sell and they
are the only provider of inpatient
children psychiatric services in our
state
so when we reviewed
the fact that they were selling we felt
it was important to secure this service
for the citizens of new hampshire we all
know that for the past several years
we've had
several children waiting in the
emergency room for inpatient psychiatric
care
anywhere from 10 to up to 20 right right
now i think we're right around the 20
mark
those are kids that potentially are
going to go to hampstead
once it's purchased and the capacity is
expanded we know that right now they're
operating at a census of 45 they have
capacity for 111
due to some staffing issues they have
not been able to expand their services
our goal is to
purchase hampstead
contract with a third party to to assist
in running it similar to the contract at
new hampshire hospital and expand those
services both by by bed number and by
specialty services so we have several
gaps in our children's system
you are all familiar with the children's
behavioral health system of care
that continuum requires inpatient
children
care for for psychiatric care
so we will be looking at expanding acute
inpatient beds but also looking at
whether it is an appropriate site for
for longer term
psychiatric residential treatment
programs
we will be looking at adults that are 18
to 25 that currently reside in the adult
program and whether they're more
appropriate to be in a special program
um located at hampstead
so right now we're still in the middle
with the purchase and sales have not
been signed this is just the part where
we accept the federal funds so that we
can do the contracting process with
hampstead the contract itself will go to
governor and council and then the
operating budget obviously would come
back to fiscal in a variety of forms
the the questions around workforce and
things like that the personnel that are
currently there our intent is not to
have anybody lose their jobs we will
have a third party maybe leadership
maybe state employees
but the intent is to continue with their
employment uh through a third party
i i got a further question yes ma'am
chair i think i think i have uh two more
follow-ups if i might but uh
so um so
so as you know uh we've been looking uh
with the special committee to take a
look at the the uh closure and
replacement of the sununu center yes and
um
i i i just because we were talking about
it yesterday morning in our final
meeting of that committee i'm just
curious if you have any sort of uh
you know i'm not going to hold you to it
i'm just looking for sort of an initial
gut reaction
of whether or not it there is a a
feasibility
to having
sort of the sununu center
the clinical
residential portion of it moved over
there because we're trying to get away
from incarceration and more into
counseling and caregiving and so
co-location seems to have some benefits
do you have sort of a just sort of an
initial reaction of you know no never
and it would never make any sense to
and it's worth looking at
so um i wouldn't recommend that you
co-locate
the youth at
sununu center within the hospital of
hampstead hospital but the campus itself
is 110 acres i think the the goal
looking at the replacement facility for
sununu is that we're looking at any
state-owned properties and how that
could be developed if the state
purchases property i would assume that
we are also going to review this
property for is an appropriate setting
now the overall goal for the department
is to create a children's uh
system of care and a
center of excellence for chi for youth
behavioral health
we certainly want to extend that center
of excellence into the youth that are
that are at syse right now
whether it can be located on the same
campus is not something that we've
reviewed at this point
and then one more if i may yes go ahead
so
i
we're just having manpower problems all
over the state and i think hampstead
hospital has suffered from workforce
shortages um
what what what is what is your
sense
that
we're going to be able to figure out how
to get the manpower or the workforce in
there
that would be adequate
to making hampstead hospital truly a
business viable concern
hampstead hospital in its
in the current form is a viable business
that has been operated as a private
business for 40 years um with that truck
with the trust that it that it's uh that
it works with
so
the intent is to partner with a third
party and to offer employment for the
vast majority of the hampstead staff
between the state and the third party
collaboration it is that point that we
need to look at
hiring additional staff to increase
services but right now they're operating
at 45 beds and we anticipate that the
vast majority of staff are going to want
to come over and work with
either the state or the third party
partner
and i just one last one
uh uh
thank you madam chairman i i this is my
last question i do do you happen to know
what the hampstead hospital's uh
prospective policy is on mandating the
covet vaccination for all employees i do
not
do could you could you just check into
it and have someone just let me know
sure all right thank you
senator mars
thank you madam chair
um thank you commissioner having been
involved in this since the beginning
um i don't think this is any surprise
the speaker and i were briefed on this a
while ago i think
it's not
it doesn't happen every day that the
state is able to get into a purchase and
sales agreement
which they have to treat like any other
business would have it was kept silent
for a long period of time i can assure
you it's the intention at least on
the senate side that we want to be
involved in the creation in the future
of this and
i think questions of whether or not the
employees are going to be there and
working for the state or working for
some other organization
we don't want to see any employees go
anywhere right now in the state of new
hampshire um so i guess we can send that
message to everybody including the
hospitals to put out a statement
yesterday
that we want to make sure every employee
stays right where they are so having
said that this is a great idea i
appreciate what you're doing right now i
appreciate the fact that we're going to
build something great here because
as a senator when i get these phone
calls and someone's in the hospital for
12 days and the mother's sitting right
there alongside the child
we need more and we know that and this
was a good solution um
a quite affordable price because we're
building other right now buildings for
25 people that are a heck of a lot more
money than this triple this amount of
money um and to be able to buy this and
have the extra land that hampstead
hospital has
on that campus i think we can do some
great things there and i appreciate the
work you've put into this thank you
senator you know i want to stress that
when we began the negotiations with
hampstead their main concern in this
negotiation was one that we maintain the
mission of the facility and they have a
great reputation in the community and
two that we take care of their team
and we are committed to doing both of
those things with the hampstead team and
maintaining the mission of hampstead
hospital so i agree with you i think it
is uh
a long-term solution and a great
investment for our state
thank you senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair
um i'd like to just circle back to your
comment that the operating budget would
be run through fiscal committee
or through the budget depending on when
it when it happens
it would definitely be through the
fiscal committee because if it if it's
not this fiscal year to the next fiscal
year which will still be before another
budget is created
so the last paragraph of the letter
speaks to why the operating budget isn't
presented at the same time as this item
there is a
a number of things we need to continue
to research and determine before we can
determine the operating budget
so there would not be a
i mean the senate's in in filing period
right now you're not looking
to have the entire legislature weigh in
through a
special appropriation
i i don't think so i think that um
we wouldn't be requesting general funds
for this fiscal year or next fiscal year
if uh additional funds are necessary we
would request arpa funds
um so that would come here through the
fiscal committee thank you
are there any further questions
representative leishman
thanks madam shearer
i've always been concerned with late
items
i think some of us received information
as late as late yesterday afternoon
i don't dispute senator morse's
statements that this is needed this is a
great opportunity but
i have real reservations how quickly
this is moving
the commitment the state would be making
by acquiring this facility and then the
funding of this facility
as you stated
you have not put together any sort of
operating budget at this time and you
specifically say in your letter to us
that there won't be a request for
general funds
so i'm concerned madam chair that this
is moving a little too fast i think
uh i can't support the item as it's
being presented today i think what would
be more appropriate is that
the chair of your calling scheduled a
meeting so this can be discussed by
itself give the public a little more
input in the process but i cannot
support it as it's been presented thus
far and i i'm sorry because i know a lot
of people have spent some time on this
like senator morris has said but
i'd like to see more information i
believe the request that is before us is
just a little vague
may i clarify something
yes we did not state in the letter that
general funds would not be requested
i i don't believe that as stated in the
letter
i could read it to you
it says in the event of these federal
funds become no longer available general
funds will not be requested to support
this program honestly i would read that
is that the hospital would be the
program carrying forward it's on page
two
or at the bottom of uh what i have here
that was presented um
two of two
i think you might be on item uh
315.
it says 314 as it was in my package okay
that must be incorrect because i have
314 in front of me not having that
statement 315 does 314 has three pages
three fourteen has two pages yeah excuse
me just a second uh representative
leitchman i know that you were
not
available for pre-fiscal
uh however um we had a copying glitch
okay okay
yes
and we made sure you got it
yeah so um thanks i i figured you were
behind it yeah you got you got the
glitch uh what happened is they uh
accidentally
attached 315
second page to 314 and vice versa
so um
senator morris
thank you madam chair
representative leachman we just wanted
to see if you were reading it um
yeah
um
mr kane said he's bad so i think well
the um and maybe the commissioner can
clarify things because i didn't sit on
the last budget but i sat on this
current one um
when
we tried to solve problems with
new hampshire hospital
we were moving the children out of new
hampshire hospital to create 50 beds
because every child you take out you can
get two
we ran into glitches i believe last year
where we had to find room for children
i don't know for all of us that have
been involved in mental health since
2014 and trying to restructure things in
the state of new hampshire
all we're asking today
is the 15 million to take out of opera
to finish negotiating a deal that is in
place um
which
can't be more public than it is today
quite honestly but
i don't think you could find a hundred
bed hospital for 15 million dollars or
whatever that purchase price is within
that 15 million dollars
it just i don't see how it could happen
this is some group of people at the
other end that are trying to help the
state of new hampshire
and what i believe has become a crisis
now along with that i believe the
commission is working with several of
the hospitals to create more drff beds
in the state of new hampshire
but all of these things and this is what
i assured the senate this morning are
going to go through a senate process of
how to operate it and what the expenses
are going to be
and how new hampshire will use it but i
don't think there was ever a time
where we said we didn't need drf beds
for children
and that's what this is attempting to
solve and even if you were only solving
it for the 25 children that we moved out
of new hampshire hospital
we're not building anything right now
that's less than 30 million dollars
for
25 units
and we're going to get a 100 bed unit
and we're going to get all that extra
land it just happens to be down by my
district so i know exactly where it is
this this is a good investment for the
state of new hampshire how you operate
it will become your good investment it
will become
all of the legislature to be honest with
you because i don't see how you can make
a decision just with fiscal on this i i
think it's going to take both you know
finance committees and the health
committees to come up with the plan to
work with the commissioner on and it's a
long way in the out that's why the
governor didn't answer those questions
when he broke this the other day but
quite honestly securing this and getting
the deal done is equally as important as
operating it in my opinion and that's
what today's about and and i actually
would appreciate your vote because i
know the speaker's been briefed on this
the whole time i was briefed on it um
and keeping things quiet around here are
tough i actually got phone calls about
this in the middle of it
where people from the outside knew more
than i did um and
i said i can't talk about it so i'm not
ducking anything right now i certainly
have been part of that mental health
changeover in the state and to me
this is something that really benefits
the state of new hampshire
thanks for your comments
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair
at the top of page three
the the land acquisition and the
easement paragraph
which i think is the correct
um copy
yes yes but i think i understand that
that
basically hampstead is running a profit
of 15 million dollars at least
and that
that income
they're expecting is at least 15 million
dollars above what their
liabilities are and so we might you're
expecting we won't even need the
15 million dollars of arpa funds
anyway
when will we know that
so
um
the purchase is actually the first
expense line 33
which is described at the bottom of page
two that just says purchase of property
so that's related to the 13 million
the two million dollars uh i should have
clarified that when i put that in the
narrative i apologize is the top of page
three and that two million dollars is
part of the uh structure of the purchase
and sales
there's a
structure between accounts payable and
accounts receivable that essentially
becomes our responsibility once we're
once we've purchased it and so this is
just to help manage that it's really a
cash flow issue
um
and so those offer funds shouldn't be
needed
hopefully once that closes out we're
still working out how that will work
exactly but i wanted to make sure that
we could pay the bills that will need to
be paid
follow-up
that's
two two is my hope
they may end up need some of it but at
this point that's my hope is that that
won't be actually needed it's more of a
cash flow issue
senator d'alessandro you have a question
thank you thank you madam chip
excuse me i did have a couple one was
the 13 was for the building
the the the two million is for the land
who made the that assessment
so the the 2 million is not for the land
the 13 million is for the building and
the landed for the entire purchase and
sales the 2 million is for the accounts
payable accounts receivable transactions
but on the front page it says land in
acquisition payments 2 million is that a
mistake unfortunately there's no other
class line that really uh was
appropriate to to use um and we try not
to create new class lines for one
transaction so because it is related to
the purchase and sales i discuss with
the department of administrative
services and use the same class line
okay
but indeed if i were reading this i
would be misled
well that's why i put the explanation on
the top of page three
i'm definitely trying not to i tried to
include a lot more detail as promised at
the last meeting i appreciate that
um
let me just say that
quickly because i've spent a lot of time
on this we've been in the dark on this
really and i understand what senator
moses said
i have complete confidence in what he
has done
and i will support this based on his
assurance
a that the deal will be consummated
properly under state regulations etc and
that
what we really really need is a place to
put our children
now i've talked with heather oakland
more than anybody has in this in this
board i'm sure
sometimes on a daily basis about who's
in the waiting room children and adults
we took the children out
to create beds for the adults we had to
reintroduce the children because we
didn't have a place for them hampstead
couldn't take them just couldn't take
the volume so we recreated 10 beds at
the hospital there was a cost associated
with both of those things
retrofitting for 40
re-retrofeeding for 10
after you have retrofitted for 40. we
put 5 million dollars aside for that in
in the last operating budget
i'd like us to use our money wisely
i mean that's that's why we're own
oversight committee but as i said i'll
vote for the issue senator morse based
on on you
i have great confidence in you as a as
the president of the senate if you come
to me and tell me it's a good situation
i'm buying it
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any other questions
or comments
um
representative leitchman thanks madam
chair
commissioner do you have a rough idea
you must have some you know
figures on a napkin somewhere the cost
of running this facility should you be
successful in acquiring it
i only have um we have what uh it cost
hampstead to run their facility um so
the current beds the intent would be
obviously to take over that operation
and then um
do additional beds and additional
services beyond what they are currently
doing there are some uh different
reimbursement sources that are going to
engage enter into this equation such as
dish
payments when we get when it becomes
state-owned so
yes we we could look at what hampstead
um paid or what what their operating
expenses were um and what the net is i
can tell you that prior to covid um they
were net positive
meaning that their revenue was more than
their expenses um that that will change
as we as we move into different areas of
care and we we take more um
medicaid kids uh less kids from out of
state things like that
but prior the year prior to covet
they were net positive
thank you and i do have a statement
there's very few people i respect more
than senator morris so i will be voting
uh following his lead madam chair
thank you very much representative
leishman
and thank you senator mars
uh representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair just uh as i was sitting
here thinking about 110 acres
i don't know what the property tax
status of hampstead hospital is today it
just makes me wonder uh what the impact
is going to be on the local community is
there what is the property tax
implication of shifting this from
private hands to
um to state hands
the property tax implication is part of
the discussions that we are having right
now
so both within the purchase and sales
and with the town of hampstead uh
they've asked uh both myself and melissa
st seer to come and present to them so
it's it's going to be part of the
discussion i don't have an answer right
now
follow up
so the implica oh and i'll let senator
morris answer if he wants
yeah they've already contacted the
senator from that district so i believe
it's about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars is the property tax um
i think these things have been solved in
many different ways in the past i mean
in louis taxes and things like that
we're gonna have to look at it um we're
not
making this decision to hurt the town of
hampstead i can tell you that much
thank you
okay is there are there any other
questions
okay uh senator d'alessandro
moves uh
fis
21-3-14 seconded by
senator daniels
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed the vote is ten
zero
thank you very much and uh we now will
move to
item uh 21 315 which was also a late
item
and authorization
to accept and expend
4.6
million in our funds
so
um
you have a you have a question okay uh
oh thank you for uh returning
would you mind introducing who uh just
arrived
hi patricia tilley director of public
health
thank you very much okay
uh representative edward you have a
question uh yes ma'am i i from what i've
read on this and in our pre-fiscal i'm
i'm i'm predisposed to um
approving this but
i just want to get a couple of points
out
into the public just um given all the
concern there's been over uh vaccine
programs um and i and i i think these
things may uh
help the public know what we're doing
and support what you're asking us to do
um as i as i read this this is uh this
is 4.68 million dollars approximately
it's all 100 arpa money uh it's coming
to us without any specific strings
uh this is money that uh the state
will
um
can convert to our control
and that you'll be able to invest in
an immunization program
that sort of matches new hampshire's
culture and character
of rolling the vaccines out to make them
available on a voluntary basis to anyone
in the state that wants it is that is
that somewhat accurate or yes
um uh follow-up
please go ahead
okay and then um
we
i think
uh
i i just i think we're in a situation
where
covid is not going away it's gonna
continue to mutate into different
variants
this is a long term
issue it's not
going to go away next year it's not
going to go in five years it's probably
going to just keep on mutating we're
always going to be dealing with covet is
is is that is that
true you think
i think that there will be a point where
where it becomes endemic similar to
influenza
where there is a
baseline of covet in the communities and
like influenza
we get
many of us get flu vaccines every year
to fight the strains that are currently
circulating in the community
it is likely that covid will become
endemic and there will be a baseline in
the community for many years to come
uh thank you for that mr paul one more
follow-up yes
i've asked you a few times in a few
different settings over the last couple
of months about uh what the department's
position is relative to what we think we
know about natural immunity and what we
don't know
do you have any updates for us on on
where where the science is at in terms
of
believing that natural immunity may be a
third way we have vacs we have unvacs do
we have natural immunity and i i noticed
st luke's and
and pennsylvania has told their
employees that if they have natural
immunity they can go a year without
having to worry about fact status
do we have any new news on
natural immunity i have no new news to
share right now we share the notion that
um even if you have natural immunity a
vaccine is extra protective for you and
so we're continuing to follow the
science there we believe that the
booster in particular will give you sort
of a top off like you would top off your
gas tank we believe that that provides
extra protection um but we're continuing
to review the science as it comes in
what we do know if i can just add to
that is that in the last several months
we've watched vaccine breakthrough cases
as a percentage of our hospitalizations
increase last fiscal i talked about the
90 10 about 90 percent of people in the
hospital are unvaccinated and that's
still approximately our average over the
last 10 months but what we've seen is it
go from 90 10 in july august to 80 20 in
in september and now around 30 of our
hospitalizations are are fully
vaccinated people and what that points
us to is waning immunity um so that
that's why the boosters are so important
especially with people over 65 and
people that have underlying health
conditions
uh thank you madam chairman thank you
madam commissioner for answering the
questions
oh yes senator daniels sorry
thank you uh just to kind of follow up
on representative edward's question
because i'm not sure
that i get the exact answer uh but where
it states that this money is available
for voluntary school-based
clinics is it am i correct in
understanding
that if a school has a vaccine mandated
policy that they would not be eligible
for this money
no that's incorrect any any state funded
vaccine program
is accessible to any citizen the state
citizen in the state regardless of their
their reason or their desire for getting
the vaccine
so along with
the school-based clinics or uh the the
fqhcs which will be holding vaccine
clinics across the state
if there is a mandate from an employer
or
something like that
they would still have accessibility to
that to that vaccine um i think we've
been clear
for for months now that the state will
not have a vaccine mandate and we don't
support a federal vaccine mandate
so so how can one have a voluntary
school-based clinic with a
mandated policy
um we don't mandate anything the
department of health and human services
would not mandate it the division of
public health would not mandate it um if
if there is a mandate by an individual
organization an individual private
business that is out of the control of
the state government
but the accessibility to the to the
vaccine is for everyone regardless of
their reasons
once again if i may i want to i want to
read what it says to support clover 19
vaccine delivery
within voluntary school based clinics
and
i'm trying to figure out what a
voluntary school-based clinic is that me
to that to me that means that they have
not adopted a mandated vaccine policy
yes similar to how we do uh flu clinics
right now we're doing flu clinics in
schools for voluntary school-based
clinics for the influenza vaccine very
similar to that program that we've run
all along
no i i think i would just
suggest that the voluntary school-based
clinics we will be funding our regional
public health networks the regional
public health work networks nor the
fqhcs have any mandates to the
commissioner's point someone who arrives
at one of those clinics may be doing
that for a variety of reason but the
voluntary clinic is that the clinic
itself is voluntary
thank you
are there any further questions
senator gaiden
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
my concern is about the date of privacy
i'm not sure that you're on
that's tess
okay bring it closer thank you sorry
yeah my concern is about the privacy of
data the collection of any data can you
expound on what will be collected and
where it will go and how it may be
protected
so uh covert vaccine data is required to
be reported to the cdc um all of our
vaccine providers report that through
one of many ways either directly to the
cdc or through our vaccine registry with
an opto clause
follow-up yes thank you madam chair um
can you describe the opt-in process is
it just a one-time uh is there
um
is that a blanket opt-in for boosters
going forward
again i'm concerned about the the right
of an individual to withdraw from a
program once they've started way down
that road our vaccine registry statute
is an opt out not an opt in but i'm
going to have trisha explain the
difference between opt out and
withdrawal
sure thank you senator so at every
vaccine opportunity you will be provided
with an opt-out option especially within
these clinics right here in our
federally qualified health centers and
our regional public health networks i
will say that there are some farm retail
pharmacies that have a direct
relationship with the federal government
they are currently not sending us any
data and so you may not get an opt-out
in those environments because they're
not sending us their data anyway at this
moment
yes so can you explain about this opt
out process
my understanding is it's maybe a little
bit convoluted it's not like you sign a
form saying i opt in
you just don't
not opt-in can you help me with that
sure so everyone who receives a vaccine
by one of that by one of our registered
providers so they're they're in a
relationship with the department and the
immunization information system which is
what we call our registry
they are supposed to educate their
patient and say if you want to opt out
this is how you do it there is a one
simple form you sign it and the provider
then provides that information to us so
we can i and they they take care of it
within their system
it is currently under our current rules
i believe you would need to have an
opt-out at every time you get vaccinated
it's part of the reason we were looking
at
changing those rules to make it a little
bit easier for individuals but we know
that the legislature is going to want to
weigh in on what that process looks like
in the future so we held off so that we
could um hear what the legislature wants
in the direction they want to go
follow
okay just to remind you that
this
fis is not dealing with the
vaccine registry
so if we could focus on
the 4.6 i would appreciate it madam
chair if i may um
i think in the process of receiving
the vaccination it would invoke
participation in the registry and for
that reason i'd ask to continue that's
why
go ahead thank you
so does the department require
a form to be provided to anyone coming
to get a vaccine
what we provide is to to our providers
we inform them how the opt out process
works it is a incumbent upon the
providers themselves to make that
information available to their patients
follow up so what we have is no no
assurance really that a provider is in
fact complying with the law regarding
the privacy so we have a monitoring
process that we do we do monitoring both
from a federal perspective we have to
monitor the use in in the distribution
of any vaccine right now and we also
work very closely with all of our
providers to ensure that they have the
education that they need in order to
meet our statute
thank you madam chair you're quite
welcome if i understood correctly if
if i go to a pharmacy
they don't
even report it generally to
the state it goes directly to the cdc
that is correct yeah and so
um
if people are concerned about the
privacy of their
vaccine
status
they should in fact go to one of the
state authorized
clinics
these clinics have a direct relationship
with the federal government um and they
are providing vaccine through the
through the federal vaccine program not
necessarily the state
they do not report into our registry um
the
the solution to have them reporting into
our registry was in the was in the prior
um
the prior items the 22 million
which was the the registry items there's
no no money in this 4.68
million that uh supports the registry
outside of uh senators guida statement
that you know people that get the vax
the vaccine will either be reported to
uh the cdc through the federal program
or through the state registry
if they don't opt out if they don't if
they don't opt out and we have done
education we we sent a a a memo in july
making sure that all providers knew that
they had to provide an opt-out notice to
their to their patients so
outside of standing in the clinic and
making sure they're doing it we've
provided all the education we can to our
providers
thank you could i have a motion to
all right senator d'alessandro second
seconded by sen representative edwards
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
the vote is ten zero uh if you don't
mind i would ask you to stay there just
a second please
okay
uh
thank you
um
next is tab 12 the information items
and the reason that i asked you to stay
is um
the
the report that you provided on
granite advantage health care
and i just wanted to say that
that was an excellent report
and i wanted to
just express my appreciation for
getting that to us
um i know we didn't have a dashboard
this month
but i'm sure
we've had a few things going on but uh
in in november
we'll have a dashboard
so
are there any other questions on for the
information items
okay seeing none uh thank you very much
commissioner
thank you
okay
yeah
yep that's next
okay
i understand our auditors are here
someplace
working their way through they're
working their way through okay
and um
we will be talking about the audit
from the uh
on the department of labor
yes and why we're waiting it's up to you
but if you want to make a motion to
release this uh to the public you could
do that now while you're waiting it's up
okay
madam
chair uh i move to accept i'm not still
not on
i move to accept the report place on
file and release in the usual manner
second
second by senator guida
all those in favor please raise your
hand
okay we've got five six seven okay eight
zero yes thank you
thank you
red
red button down
there you go thank you
good morning madam chair members of the
committee uh for the record steve smith
director of audits for the lba
we're here to present our financial
audit on the department of labor for the
nine months ended march 31st 2001.
joining me from our office is colin
quinn he's was a manager on the auto job
and he will uh present our portion
and also joining us from the department
of labor is uh commissioner maryfield
for any comments he may have or to
answer any questions you have so steve
we're not
it's not real clear so could you bring
your mic a little closer sure
oh that's much better okay thank you
i've been known to be very soft-spoken
it's fine
so with that i'll turn it over to um
colin and he can present
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee can you hear me all right
is that okay
for the record my name is colin quinn
we're here this morning to present the
report on our financial audit like steve
said of the department of labor for the
nine months ended march 31st 2021
this report is presented in two sections
the first section being the management
letter section prepared by the auditors
and it contains our report on internal
control and compliance along with 10
audit observations which is followed by
the current status of prior audit
findings
the second section the financial section
contains our independent auditor's
report followed by the department
prepared financial payments and notes
the focus of my presentation today will
be on the observations and
recommendations however we would be
happy to answer any questions that you
may have regarding any part of this
report
if you turn to the table of contents you
will note that this report contains
seven internal control observations none
of which were considered to be material
weaknesses
in addition we also have three state
compliance comments one of those
observation number nine is identified as
suggesting legislative action may be
required
the department did concur with all 10 of
the comments
the observations begin over on page 3
with the first three observations
discussing the need to implement formal
policies and procedures
turning over to page three observation
number one recommends the department
implement formal policies and procedures
to strengthen its review of second
injury fund medical disbursements
control activities such as review and
approval are an essential component of
internal controls and an expansion of
the department's controls over this
process could help reduce the risk of
errors and omissions
we recommend the department implement a
process to obtain and review supporting
documentation from insurance carriers on
a sample basis for requested medical
cost reimbursements
observation number two over on page four
notes the department had not established
policies and procedures to ensure that
monthly reconciliations are performed
between the department's subsystem and
new hampshire first
policies and procedures are an
organization's primary control process
for ensuring that appropriate operating
criteria are regularly met over time
especially in times of transition
we recommend the management implement
formal policies and procedures including
reconciling to appropriate money market
accounts and a review and approval
function for monthly reconciliations
between the subsystem and new hampshire
first
turning the page to page five
observation number three again
recommends the department implement
policies and procedures with this
observation related to review and
approval of bi-weekly payroll
during the audit period
the bi-weekly payroll of the department
ranged from a low of approximately 155
000 to a high of approximately 184
thousand
a formal documented review would help
ensure that management understands and
accepts any payroll changes that occur
in a given period
the next four observations numbers four
through seven starting on page six all
related to internal control deficiencies
over information technology
and observation number four recommends
the department continue with its efforts
to replace the outdated as400 computer
system
the department relies on this system for
the tracking of revenues and accounts
receivable financial reporting and also
case management
there was an august 1999 strategic plan
commissioned by the department
that advised that the as400 system be
retired in approximately 14 to 16 months
now more than two decades later the
system is still in use
necessary personal resources should be
devoted to properly design develop and
implement a replacement system without
delay
turning the page observation number five
recommends an i.t security management
program be established including
subordinate plans at the agency level
where necessary
without a well-designed and communicated
security management program there is the
risk that security controls may be
insufficient that responsibilities may
be unclear
or that controls may be inconsistently
applied
in conjunction with this program we also
recommend the department continue to
make every effort to protect its
information systems from cyber security
risks
turning the page again observation
number six recommends the establishment
of a formal service level agreement with
the department of information technology
in order to provide clarity as to doit
versus department responsibilities as
they relate to various information
technology areas
and then observation number seven
recommends the department's existing
continuity of operations plan be tested
on a regular basis in order to allow the
department to make adjustments where
necessary
over on page 11 we have the start of our
compliance comments with observation
number eight discussing the department's
administration fund assessment which is
established in statute for the sole
purpose of administering the workers
compensation chapter
the department's fiscal year 21 budget
appears to over allocate the cost of
administering workers compensation
programs and as you can see illustrated
in the chart at the bottom of page 11
the assessment funded 80.9 percent of
the department's fiscal year 21 budgeted
costs including 90 percent of the
administrative support costs and 49.4
percent of budgeted inspection division
costs
we recommend the department reevaluate
its policies and procedures related to
the administration fund assessment to
ensure that insurance carriers and
self-insurers are equitably charged
turning the page observation number nine
addresses statutes that appear to
conflict
the department deposits penalties
collected under rsa 275 a5 into the
restricted fund which conflicts with rsa
273 11a which requires penalties to be
deposited into the general fund
we recommend the department seek to
amend this conflicting language
our final observation is observation
number 10 on page 14
and it addresses financial disclosure
forms required by rsa 15a and recommends
the department continue in its efforts
to have all required filers associated
with the department file the required
reports
then if you turn the tab over on page 16
you'll notice an index which reports the
current status as of october 12
of the observations contained in the
fiscal year 2010 department of labor
management letter as noted at the bottom
of page 18 11 of the comments were fully
resolved and three were in the process
of remediation
the financial section of the report
follows with our auditor's opinion which
was modified as a complete set of
financial statements was not presented
the general fund statement of revenues
and expenditures is on page seven and
the fiduciary fund financial statements
are on pages eight and nine
which are then followed by the notes to
the financial statements
with that this concludes my presentation
i would like to thank the department and
also the department of administrative
services for the assistance we received
during the audit the commissioner and
his staff were very responsive to all of
our requests and comments
and at this time we'd be happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have
senator daniels thank you i have a
question on uh observation number five
on page seven
my question is why is it a deficiency
against the department when it is the
responsibility
of uh do it to develop and implement a
strategy
i think that
i think the um
obviously the department bears
first and foremost responsibility to to
protect um but i think that um if i if i
may
we have um
uh
john clinchy is uh it does a lot of rit
auditing and he crafted this response
so i think and actually had specific
conversations with doit as the basis of
this if i may like to call him ford
maybe he can respond
to this
sir certainly
good morning for the record my name is
john clinch i'm a senior audit manager
with the office of legislative budget
assistant
um
the reason um we put it in this report
was we felt it was a shared
responsibility of both the department of
information technology and the
department of labor
uh the way the security breaks down in
the state is the resp the
department of information technology is
responsible for some things and the
department of labor is responsible for
others
and that's why we included it in the
report because it is critical to the
financial statements
that the data be protected
yeah just to follow up
but it does happen it's actually in
quotes
that
doit
is responsible for quote developing and
implementing a strategy to address cyber
security so i would expect to see such a
deficiency in an audit against doit but
i was just curious as to
why the department of labor
would would be
held efficient
in doing that when it clearly states
that it's the responsibility of a
different department
right um
currently we're not doing an audit of
the department of information technology
so we don't really have a vehicle to
publicly disclose that there is no
security plan
written security plan for the state
we felt that it was important enough to
put in this report and get the
department of information technology's
response on record and to let you folks
know about the situation
thank you
are there any further questions
yes representative edwards uh i'll i'll
stay on uh observation five but madam
chair i'd also like to talk about four
and nine
um on on uh observation five uh i'm i'm
an old um privacy and security guy and i
noticed your paragraph is labeled i t
security and i don't see the word
privacy so would you
tell me what your audit philosophy is as
you're looking at i.t security the
extent to which you do or do not
consider the privacy issues also
i think privacy is embedded in security
you can't have privacy without security
so security is more of a global term
as far as audit goes we look at the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of data
systems
for standards we use
the federal information system
control audit manual
and that
discusses
security in a broad manner and again
within that is confidentiality
but it's not specifically called out
follow-up go ahead so so just just so
you know i've just been talking and
musing with a lot of people that given
that we pass a privacy
constitutional right in 2018 that
overall the state government may want to
improve its culture relative to a
privacy by design everywhere just
a comment uh and then uh
madam chair uh
observation four
okay um i would like to read a quote
from here because i think the public
should hear this
on page six
second paragraph from the bottom the
final couple sentences
a strategic plan commissioned by the
department and facilitated by
pricewaterhousecoopers in august of 1999
advised the department to retire the
as400
in 14 to 16 months
the good news is the department
requested funds in this current fiscal
year to fully mitigate this old it
system
and so
i i don't think you have audit findings
in here relative to the failure of the
legislature or or maybe the governor's
office
but
i could could you talk to us a little
bit about
how it's possible to go 20 years with
the system that we know needs to be
replaced and what
really structurally
the way
of of doing the doing the job when it
needed to be done
i think i'd like to refer that to the
commissioner of
labor uh to better answer that question
he's more familiar with the history of
that project
good morning uh ken merrifield
commissioner of the department of labor
i can tell you
only with first-hand knowledge of the
last four years uh that it became
obvious to me immediately that our
systems were antiquated needed to be
replaced the the greater need presently
was to replace our document management
system uh which is some 20 years old and
not supported in current uh operating
system environments
so that was the first phase
but
no kidding this week we had a vendor on
site who is in charge of that project to
talk about full migration off of the
system and as as you correctly point out
we've uh requested funds to do exactly
that
prior prior administrations i
i can't really comment i don't know why
follow up
go ahead i appreciate it it's difficult
even if you wanted to or knew
why the legislature and the governor has
failed for 20 years
but i get to uh over to observation
i think it's nine
where you you list some rsas
and it just makes me wonder if we should
put
into legislation some sort of a
strategic
planning function for it
so that we we see on you know on a
five-year forecasted basis what the i.t
uh upgrades are needed to be anticipated
and and maybe right into the legislation
some sort of formal sign off or vote by
the legislature to indicate you know yes
we accept your plan or know we reject
your plan because i think we need to get
on the record um
going 20 years with an as400 is an
embarrassment and i i would i'm sorry
that we send uh representative or uh
commissioner goulet around the nation uh
with that kind of
a track record that he's got to carry
with him so
um so if you have any thoughts on what
we might need to do
to embed strategic i.t planning in a
forecasted basis so that we are more
responsive i i'd be interested in your
thoughts
yes uh please come up
[Music]
i think i i i would agree with that i
think that's something that we can
certainly work on and you know we can
work on developing information related
to that and get that to you
good morning madam chair um members of
the committee um dennis goulet
commissioner of the department of
information technology they're actually
um representative edwards um to to
directly address your your comment in
question
the uh there already is in statute
actually a strategic planning function
that's required by each agency it's
called the agency information technology
plan or aitp
could you get closer to the mind yes
sorry
we we do that on a biennial basis
aligned with the budget process so so my
vision is and we've been working on um
that document over the years it's always
been required that the agency do it
we've sort of taken over responsibility
in statute it says the agency needs to
do it but i i require that our folks do
it we have in each agency we have an i.t
lead function
uh commissioner mary field and and i
just hired a new i.t lead for for
for his organization which we're excited
about because i believe we'll be able to
make a lot more progress than we have
historically in that in the areas that
that we're addressing and talking about
today but essentially what i expect is
that and we also have an overall i.t
strategy function in fact
in early november we have a i.t council
meeting again a statutory body
i.t governance for the state of new
hampshire will be i expect will be
ratifying our updated strategic plan at
that time that's on the 5th of november
so my expectation is that an aitp or
agency information technology plan
would accurately state what the
strategic citizen service and other
requirements
for the agency and that would roll up to
our strategic plan the overall statewide
strategic plan and it would align with
the budget requests that the agency is
making
in that biennial budget cycle
a quick follow-up
yes so so i i thank you for that uh
commissioner uh is is is the short story
there that you think that the planning
mechanisms are now uh appropriate
and adequate so that we don't run into
these 20-year gaps again
well the um you know again i
i don't know that
you know when i look i wasn't aware of
that finding from 99 so uh thanks for it
educating me on that but
um
you know the
the the fact remains that um
you know while we well we are not happy
we have an as400 there and we certainly
need to modernize it um we are running
the business on that and and and so it's
not um there's not any you know giant
problems with that other than it really
does need to be modernized
um
with our new it lead there and and one
of the things we've been doing is
over the years that i've been here which
is just now uh working on i don't want
to cut you off but i i will i was just
looking for a yes or no i think the
procedures are now adequate so we're not
going to yeah i think having advanced
the
strategic planning function at
department of labor and other agencies i
believe that we're we're doing a better
job than we ever have we will continue
to improve though you're never good
enough
thank you
representative emrick you have a
question yes madam chair thank you
commissioner
am i on
no
okay
this is annoying
and my phone rings at the same time
there seemed to be a little push back
about cyber security
uh
that and
it seems to be a gap in understanding
that
you're responsible for cyber cyber
security for the state
are departments really responsible for
cyber security as well
well it is true that it's a shared
responsibility um
just for example when you when you look
at a ransomware attack in any successful
ransomware attack in any um
in any organization it's typically an
employee that clicked on the link you
know so it's i think we all we do have a
shared responsibility
uh the and i think it was pretty well
explained um you know my
my response to the cyber security
finding um was um that i concurred in
part and it was mostly because i think
that
you know when when when asked the
question you know what is your
um cyber security strategic plan and how
does it relate to how we're operating
inside the agencies we didn't have an
updated document on that so that's
something that i've taken as an action
item and you know to cure what what i
didn't feel is that there is a material
um
problem with cyber security at the
department of labor at this moment
and we have um
we're applying pretty tight guidelines
much tight you know a lot much tighter
than a lot of other states as it relates
to security and privacy in new hampshire
and we continue to work on that the
legislature's been great in
appropriating capital funds each time as
we request to keep up with our you know
our enemies frankly
uh so
so
you know my my thought on this is that
we we need to
update our now six-year-old cyber
security strategy
and get that ratified by the i.t council
um and and continue to evolve our cyber
function in it and continue to um and
make it easier when a i think when the
auditors go into an agency to figure out
you know what's going on there that we
can give answers more crispy
follow-up
my concern comes from whenever whenever
i hear the term we have shared
responsibility
it's like doubles in tennis
and we both watched the ball hit the
strike between us
so that's
somebody has to be in charge i mean and
and i'm i think it's your i would be
looking to you to provide them guidance
uh and get on your train rather than
have two different trains yes i i agree
and and i will i will i will state that
i i'm the i'm responsible my
department's ultimately responsible for
the security of the data and systems in
new hampshire
thank you commissioner
thank you are there any further
questions
uh mr merriweather i'm not going to let
you get by without
answering or talking about it or
whatever
i'm sorry for for what it's worth i
think senator d'alessandro
oh
oh okay
okay sorry
okay uh my only comment you need to pull
the mic
is that better yes uh uh my only comment
would be that uh i really admired the
professionalism of the lba in this this
process uh as you might imagine for a
small agency it is a very difficult
process
myself our cfo amy o'hara the deputy
commissioner and the uh rudy ogden who's
with us today and also the director of
the workers compensation division really
we were the people
involved in providing data and
documentation to the lba for greater
than six months i think uh so it is uh
a very in-depth process but they probed
our strengths as well as our weaknesses
made us aware of certain control
situations that we we did not realize so
as a very very good process for us and
will help us grow as an agency and i'm
grateful
to the lba for the process
are there any questions
i do have one
i know the audit identified
some legislative action
uh have you contacted anyone to um
make the change
uh we have not we have made similar
changes because
when the legislature in 2011
created the restricted fund there were
several vestigial statutes just like
this
uh some of those four i believe four of
those statutes were directing funds not
to the restricted fund but to dedicated
funds so in the review of uh
uh
dedicated funds we discovered that that
was changed in house bill 4 in the last
biennium
but we did not realize that this one
still existed
um so we'll we will seek
legislative change i'm not exactly sure
when the senate closes
the 27th
so
i think you can just
go to one of the senators and
say this is an audit finding
you know will you submit this so sure
there are 24 of them and i'm sure
any one of them would be more than happy
to uh to take care of this excellent we
will do that okay
other is are there any other
questions um
obviously
this audit sparked a lot of interest
on the part of the
fiscal committee
so um i definitely want to thank
the audit group for obviously doing a
good job and i want to thank um mr
merriweather for
his
his work and understanding and
knowing that things will get better
that's uh that's always what
audits are supposed to do
so
uh
is there okay think oh did you have
something else to say just that the
committee needs to accept oh we did we
did that when you're coming over yeah
when you were i don't know where you
were hiding somewhere
miss that thank you yeah but that that's
okay that's okay so um next meeting
um
oh i'm sorry excuse me
i can't hear you
at our last meeting we requested that
the department of education come back
here on october 1st
and give us an update on the voucher
plan now i don't see the commissioner
here uh i don't know who's here from the
department of education that's going to
bring that report to us
but it seems to me everyone knew
that that report was due on the 1st of
october
so indeed if it's not here it better be
here for the next meeting yes
i spoke to mr kane about this
um yes because
i was also
totally in agreement with you senator
uh and um
so mr kane would you mind explaining
what happened
sure so uh initially october 1st the
commissioner was scheduled to give a
verbal update of the education freedom
account program
along with various details that meeting
was cancelled the commissioner was
unavailable today to present but the
department did reach out and did state
that he'd be available um for the
november meeting i will reach out to
caitlin davis and the commissioner as
well
um
and i know today with the minutes that
were amended relative to kind of what
you're looking for i'll share that with
the commissioner as well
okay thank you madam chad yes i i can't
wait um
i can't wait either i know i know i was
trying to think of something
that should not go in the minutes but uh
hopefully it won't be a turkey
so
uh seal please don't put that in okay
all right before we recess madame j i
want to compliment you on on the way
you've run the meeting i think it was
outstanding you gave everybody an
opportunity to speak handle it uh
brilliantly so kudos
thank you thank you
um
[Applause]
thank you very much
uh mr kane
i know that we had set a tentative date
yes the third uh friday in november is
the 19th if that's
okay with the members
check with us
we'll clear that department we'll make
sure that uh we'll let them know you're
expecting something the committee is
thank you sure yeah we're expecting a
lot okay
so
okay
uh if there's no other business could i
have moved towards your okay
senator senator guida moves to adjourn
seconded by senator daniels thank you
all for coming today and the work you
did prior to the meeting and
i'm really
happy that
we did well so thank you all thank you
that we all survived